[Música]
recientemente los presidentes de
Colombia Gustavo Petro y El Salvador
nayib bukele se enfrascaron en una pelea
por Twitter en la que Petro le increpó a
su homólogo por construir una mega
cárcel para presuntos pandilleros y sus
arrestos masivos en los últimos seis
meses bukele dice que sus medidas son
efectivas pero Petro responde que mejor
construir universidades Cuál es el
camino más conveniente para combatir la
delincuencia esta primera pregunta para
nuestro primero invitado del día Sergio
Rodríguez Jerez decano de la escuela de
educación de la universidad Sergio
arboleda y pht doctor en su ciudad en el
conocimiento y acción en la educación la
comunicación los derechos y las nuevas
tecnologías muchas gracias a ustedes
señor Rodríguez por estar con nosotros y
lo escuchamos
Bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación que me hacen el día de hoy y
creo que esta pregunta es extremadamente
crucial frente a lo que estamos viviendo
no solamente en Colombia sino también en
todo latinoamérica y gran parte del
mundo
el camino para combatir la criminalidad
no es un camino unilineal no tiene nada
que ver en principio con acciones
específicas sino con una serie de
acciones en diferentes frentes que nos
permiten a nosotros realmente afrontar
esta realidad el componente por ejemplo
de la criminalidad O la realidad
criminal no solamente se da por una
condición de pronto educativa sino
adicionalmente por condiciones
biológicas sociológicas culturales en
donde evidentemente la educación podría
afectar podría atacar de manera positiva
pero creo que verlo desde una sola
perspectiva dañaría un poco la la
realidad que conlleva o que implica una
situación como la que estamos viendo en
Colombia con la que está viviendo
también en otras partes del mundo Claro
pero no olvidemos que el origen de las
maras
surge en la pobreza y en la falta de
oportunidades para los gobierno
salvadoreños que con este factor Podrían
haber tenido una realidad diferente a
esta sensación de abandono por el estado
que finalmente elevó la criminalidad en
El Salvador
por eso eso es lo que hacíamos
referencia En este preciso instante con
que uno de los elementos es la condición
cultural y factores sociológicos por
ejemplo como las faltas de oportunidades
la educación entonces podría ser el
camino siempre y cuando haya una
política de articulación porque la
pregunta o la contrapregunta que se nos
viene es con que se construyan más
universidades se garantiza plenamente la
disminución de la criminalidad Y ante
esa pregunta no podríamos encontrar una
respuesta certera que dijera sí tampoco
diciendo que con que se aumenten las
cárceles Entonces se va a disminuir el
índice de criminalidad por no sé algún
tipo de dispositivo de poder de control
que haga que las personas sientan miedo
a la hora de ejecutar un crimen creo que
tomar la decisión de adaptarse a una
sociedad construir y transformar es una
decisión de voluntad y es una decisión
que tiene muchos factores sobre todo una
formación del carácter que tiene que ver
con la virtud con el desarrollo de
sociedad con la construcción por ejemplo
de conciencia Ciudadana de
de esmero por construir una mejor mejor
está tu cubo para donde el lugar en
donde no se encuentra y hay muchas
dimensiones que tenemos que atacar y
debemos ver entonces la educación o como
algo que surge de una institucionalidad
sino como algo que se ve por ejemplo en
la casa en las calles en la cultura en
todo lugar en donde uno puede ejecutar
una acción ciudadana vamos a ver algunas
de las cifras porque la disminución de
los homicidios en El Salvador ha sido
dramática desde que nayib bukele declaró
el primero de cinco estados de excepción
que van hasta el momento cerró 2022 con
menos de ocho homicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes eso es una reducción
de casi el 85% en cuatro años esto
frente a Colombia que está en 26,1 por
cada 100.000 habitantes es decir en este
momento hay más asesinatos en Colombia
que en El Salvador sin embargo ahí
Habría que ver también las
características de demográficas de cada
país yo lo que le quiero pedir es que
hablemos de estas cifras a la luz de
esas herramientas que usted considera
deberíamos implementar en los países
latinoamericanos pues para mejorar
nuestra condición de estilo de vida y de
calidad de vida para los habitantes
Claro que sí y pienso que no tenemos que
confundir la condena que se le ejecuta
una persona que por ejemplo comete algún
tipo de crimen frente a la formación o
educación que permitiría también por
ejemplo evitar este crimen una de las
cosas que a veces estamos viviendo
nosotros en el mundo académico es que se
dice que si se Por ejemplo si se forma
más pues inmediatamente Debería ser la
condena para que el que está en la
cárcel O sea que alguien condenado
reciba educación como condena O sea que
esa sea su obligación y pienso que hay
un elemento que no podemos descuidar que
es la voluntad humana la construcción de
la voluntad humana una persona que es
condenada Pues debe ser se le debe
aplicar una pena que sea evidentemente
proporcional a la compensación de
aquella acción que cometió del delito
que cometió pero de manera paralela e
incluso e incluso antes hay que trabajar
por un proceso de construcción de esa
persona desde las dimensiones que
acabamos de mencionar biológico
psicológico y sociológico para que
se evita esta situación voy a cerrar la
idea con lo siguiente y ahí para
terminar
lo importante acá es entender que si hay
un buena una buena construcción social y
un bien desarrollo individual se puede
evitar el crimen pero no se puede asumir
que con el hecho es hacer más punible el
crimen y hacerlo cada vez más exigente e
incluso afectar de pronto la dignidad
humana se evita el crimen porque se va a
estallar en algún momento de la historia
lo hemos visto en el transcurso de todos
los años que tenemos como humanidad que
un elemento específico en un tiempo sin
una construcción una transformación
completa e integral pues no era un
resultado a largo plazo Bueno ya para el
cierre aquí estamos hablando más
entonces más que de universidades o de
cárceles estamos hablando es de un
proceso de transformación social bukele
lo que eligió fue construir una cárcel
en vez de construir por ejemplo un
centro educativo en efecto este tipo de
decisiones
si hubiera elegido una universidad eso
no mejoraría la sensación de seguridad
de la ciudadanía y podemos estar de
acuerdo le pregunto profesor
en que los procesos de transformación
sociales requieren años décadas sino
generaciones para que se vean sus
efectos
sí un proceso de transformación Social
es un proceso de construcción cultural y
un ejercicio de construcción cultural
puede durar décadas por ejemplo hasta
siglos entonces la cuestión acá es saber
cómo llevarlo a cabo cómo hacerlo para
que se para que perdure a largo plazo y
que por ejemplo una acción que podría
tildarse de pronto
mediática o de un periodo de tiempo muy
corto realmente genere frutos en el
mañana que es lo más importante y así lo
esperamos gracias a usted Sergio
Rodríguez seres decano de la escuela de
educación de la universidad Sergio
arboleda en Colombia por presentarnos su
punto de vista y por llevarnos Más allá
de una discusión Twitter entre dos
presidentes que tenga un feliz día
Muchas gracias a nuestros televidentes
quédense con nosotros pausa y ya
volvemos con directo a América
[Música]